i'll give you an example of investment i
made
where inflation is very extreme
and i knew it was the extreme and i
still made the investment
and
it
has worked out exceptionally well and it
will keep working out well so
i made it and since you mentioned i
think you guys got started in real
estate
i was in turkey in 2019 uh my second
trip to turkey istanbul great place i
just spent three weeks there
and
i
visited a business
where
the market cap was 20 million dollars
and
i was told that the liquidation value of
the business
was more than 800 million dollars
and so this was a company that had
12 million square feet of
warehouse space in 82 different
warehouses around turkey
a lot of it was in istanbul because
40 percent of the gdp of the country are
around istanbul but it was spread out
all over the country and there are a
bunch of other businesses besides this
that 12 million square feet
was 99 at least
long-term 10-year releases
and the tenants were blue chip cannons
amazon
ikea car for
just
awesome tenants and the leases were
inflation indexed
so every year
the rents went up based on changes to
the cpi
and
so
it took about
10 minutes to do the math i never used
the calculator
so
there was 12 million square feet
the construction cost
at that time in turkey was about 40
a square foot
and the cost of the land depending on
where you were at were between 20 and 40
square foot
so a constructed warehouse
was between 60 and 80 dollars
a square foot
so
if you took a
let's say a 70 average for example
and then you multiplied it by
70. so that's
840 billion okay so
without debt
that's the value and a lot of their
warehouse
is skew closer to 80 and 70
in terms of the actual price
and there was uh 200 million of debt
so even if you took it at 840 million
and about 200 million you have 640
million
and
the market cap is 20 million
and so basically the market cap is
sitting at something like
three percent
of the liquidation value and there were
a bunch of other businesses on top of
this business
but i didn't even care about the other
business but those were harder to value
and there was no debt on those
businesses so those are pure assets like
they run the largest
freight train network in turkey it's a
large business
they have about like 700 containers
going back and forth between turkey and
europe
and they have the largest truck fruit
and they have a
forklift
rental business and they have these
vehicle inspection stations that they
have like a
long-term contract so they're a bunch of
different businesses they're all
like monopoly or near monopoly
businesses at the time i invested it was
libra had just devalued it had gone from
3 liter i bought you a dollar to 5
and
inflation was running rampant
the expectation was
that future inflation would be 50 a year
five zero
as soon as i could
satisfy myself that there was no fraud
here
and that the things i mean i spent it
after visiting the warehouses and
[Music]
assuring myself that the
ceo and
father-son team that ran it seemed
completely above board to me and and
such
once i eliminated fraud risk
i just started buying every share i
could
and uh we owned
about 35 percent
of the company i was shocked i was able
to get that many shares so
seven million dollars bought us about 35
percent of the company
which we still owe
inflation from 2019 now
is about probably 40 50
okay
but like i told you the story of the
you know owning a home
if there's inflation in the future
and i'm not
building more warehouses
my warehouses are going up in value my
rent is going up everything's going up
and so i can't lose i can't go backwards
and so i said that i'm buying at three
percent
and i don't think i don't think there
could be value destruction
because if there's inflation then cement
prices go up steel prices go up land
prices go up everything goes up and
rents go okay
and
what the company was really good at is
in the middle they got a chance to refi
at lower interest rates so
turkey is weird they've kept their
interest rates
but inflation is running very high so
they in the from 2019 to 2022
the debt went from 200 million to 90
million they paid off a lot of debt
and the blended interest rate is 14
[Music]
on their debt so they're getting 20
20 25 cpi increases because the
government suppresses
the cpi numbers to show that the
information is lower so inflation is
really running at 50
and they only get about 25 but their
debt is at 14. so it doesn't matter you
know they're still
collecting and and debt versus the value
of the asset is almost nothing
most of it is sitting in equity
and
what they said is that
they really get a market rent
after 10 years when the tenant leaves
because in the meantime you've got this
suppressed increases in rent
so they're getting further and further
away from the market trend
finally the tenant leaves after 10 years
and then they're able to
re-rent it so there's a big shortage of
warehouses
and so
uh so probably 15 20 of the footprint is
at market trends and a lot of the older
leases are way below market so every
year the rents keep going
and which is great because and the
footprint they're not able to expand it
much because
banks are unwilling to lend and things
which i like but i just want them to
stay with that food
and
now
90 million debt
and they've
spawned a new business they're spawner
they
started a solar business
which has added about 200 million to the
intrinsic value
so the intrinsic value today in dollars
is higher than it was in 2019
the lira has gone from five liter to the
dollar when i invested to almost 14.
okay
so
we got clobbered on the lyra
the investment
is now uh the market cap is over 100
million dollars
so the the it's still deeply undervalued
but it moved up about five
okay so
and it's still got a lot of room to run
so what i'm saying is
we knew there was inflation like i know
i known already
a year from now the leader will be at
20.
and i know two years from now it'll be
at 30.
and i know the investment will still be
you know no issues and uh and so
that's an example of where
seven percent interes uh information is
you know come play at 50
and and still keep your shirt on so that
business has done well and they've been
very smart about how they've
you know used the bank debt i mean i
think the banks get host
and the depositors get hosed you know
you don't want to be sitting on bank
deposits
bank paying you 10 or something in that
environment but this that works out okay
it sounds like a big part of that
success was the ability to raise rents
for their property
and then also just that giant margin of
safety
and actually my next question would be
how did you find it was this a publicly
traded security or was it
a private business it's uh it's publicly
traded
it's still cheap
nobody wants to buy it
so
every
professional investor
has exited turkey they got freaked out
with the
back job fiscal policies
and they all sold everything and they
all left
i spent three weeks in turkey i think
it's the most amazing market to invest
in so i only look at stuff
where
i just understand the inflation is there
so for example i mean
there's a
i mean i'm not going to invest in this
i'm going to give you an example
there's a juice company in turkey
publicly traded very large tax juicers
and 98 of their product is exported
so
their costs are in libra
and their revenue is in you and turkey
is part of the european common market so
all the exports were duty-free all over
europe
so
as the
libra has depreciated
their
input costs actually have gone down
versus the euro because the
exchange rate that they convert to is so
favorable
so
wages have not kept up with inflation
and other costs have not kept up
information so this particular business
for example
does really well
in a high inflation environment so in
general
in turkey if you're a business where
your revenue is in euros or dollars
and your expenses are in turkish lira
uh a high inflation environment is not
going to affect you and a lot of
devaluation is probably going to give
you tailwinds
so
if i just limit myself to businesses
which fit that equation so even if this
company i bought
a real estate company a lot of their
leases are euro leases
so then they just automatically or they
don't even need to bother with the
exchange rate because
in lira it's so high
and uh
so
basically but but the thing is that
professional investors look at it in you
know broad spots they say oh turkey
bad economic policy crazy macro
environment whatever else better way out
of here
and when you have that type of mass
excellence
you are going to get mass missed pricing
and
so
i i found some businesses in turkey that
i think
would not be hurt with inflation not be
hurt by devaluation
and
they have a lot of tailwinds and they're
really cheap
so life is good
do you just view this as an opportunity
then to potentially acquire more shares
or
find other opportunities in that market
yeah
we are buying every day
[Music]
you